Okay, the next thing I'd like to talk about is
JSON. JSON serves the same purpose as XML, which is it's
a nice kind of computer and human readable way to
exchange data in a, in a consistent format. It stands for
JavaScript Object Notation. The reason it says JavaScript is because
JSON is actually valid JavaScript code. It might look something like
this. You know, to use kind of our travel search example
from before. We have kind of this dictionary structure. This actually
looks a lot like a Python code, because Python and JavaScript have very
similar syntax for dictionaries and lists. So,
we have this dictionary. It might have
a key called itineraries, who's value may be a list of other dictionaries. And
in this case, we have a dictionary for each routing, or something like that.
Or we have a dictionary for each leg, which may have, you know,
a key for from, and a key for to, and a value for each
of those. Now this might be, you know, leg 1, and this might be
leg 2. And you can see, you know, leg 2 is also made up
of another dictionary, which is what we use the curly
braces for. Which has a couple key value pairs of
it's own. You know, key from value IAD and key
to value SEA. And we can close our list and we
can close this dictionary. JSON is really handy for expressing
these types of objects. Anything you can express in XML you
can also express in JSON, except JSON is a little
less verbose because you don't need these kind of opening and
closing tags. You can build things up out of dictionaries or,
you know, a mapping or an object depending on what vocabulary words
you want to use, hash table, which is just a curly
and then a list of key value pairs just like you would
in Python, just like you would in JavaScript. You can also
have lists, which are, use brackets just like Python does, and separate
the values in the list with commas. So we can have 1,
2 and the string three. So we can have both integers and
strings in our lists or in the value of a hash table.
The list can also be the value of a hash table. A
list can also be an item in a list. This could look
something like this and so we've got a list inside a list here
a with two more data types, a Boolean which you are familiar
with true or false and a float. And these are basically all the
data types we can have in Jason int, string, Boolean, and float.
We can of course also have null which would be inside, for example,
the empty list. And our main data structures are
dictionaries or mapping, which is the key to a value
or multiple keys to multiple values and lists. So, what
I'd I like to show you now is how to
parse JSON in Python. Okay, we're in our Python
interpreter. We can import JSON which is, is now included
in Python's version 2.6 and newer. If your using Python
2.5, I suggest you try to find 2.6 or 2.7.
But I think app engine uses 2.7, which is what we've
been using in this class, so you shouldn't have any problem importing
JSON. If we were to make a JSON string in Python
here, let's call it j. So, if we were to take a
string to representing some JSON, in this case, it's basically a
dictionary with two keys, "one" and "numbers", and the value for "one"
is 1, and the value for "numbers" is the list [1, 2,
3.5]. Let's parse that in JSON. JSON we use the function load
S which basically stands for load string, there's also load but
that expects a file. And in this case, we're going to be
using just load S. When we run that, we get back
a Python dictionary. With our same keys, numbers and 1, you know
the order doesn't matter in python dictionaries, and our same values,
1, and 1, 2 and 3.5. And so if we were to
store that in a variable. D. We can manipulate it like
this. We can look at d numbers and we get our list.
We can look at d1 and we can see our number
one. There's actually, because JSON looks just like Python, we could actually
eval j, and what eval does is it actually treats this
as Python code as if I had just typed this at the
prompt. And this is the result we get. Now, that's a
neat thing you can do. Never, ever do it. Because in addition
to having, you know, valid JSON in here, somebody could actually
have code that might, you know, do something to your computer. So,
never use eval for parsing JSON. I just wanted
to show that you can use eval to parse
JSON. It's a really convenient thing when you're working
in Python with JSON. The two sync up very nicely.